[Music]  what is your name Walter near Walter  that is michael fassbender being a  creepy Android talking of himself and  his new movie alien covenant turns out  he's got a hidden talent even his alien  director Ridley Scott didn't know about  you know what a great dancer is uh you  don't know that that was improvised I  could have done myself some harm there  well Michael plays two androids in this  latest installment of the franchise and  at least to some interesting twists in  the sci-fi thriller which opens today  you have to kiss yourself thank you for  playing it was actually kissing guy  called tamil Sullivan it was my double  very close  [Music]  you